are you a trekkie who wants to see if
our picks line up with yours
or do you just want some shows that can
help you squeeze out a few tears
either way here are our nominations for
the saddest episodes of star trek
ever after a long and stressful mission
the crew of the defiant receives a
distress call from a starfleet captain
shipwrecked on
an inhospitable planet at first the crew
can only hear the transmission from
captain lisa cusack but can't respond
soon chief o'brien's tinkering
establishes two-way communication
with the defiance still days away and
cusack having nothing to do but slowly
suffocate cisco establishes shifts for
his officers
including himself to sit by the
communicator and keep their stranded
colleague company but some part of me is
always saying
[Music]
they may not be here tomorrow captain
cusack proves to be a gift to her
would-be rescuers with the crew
struggling under the weight of the
dominion war cusack happily gives a
sympathetic ear to their problems
she helps o'brien see he's keeping his
friends at arm's length because he's
afraid of growing too close to people
the war may take away from him
and let cisco see why having his
girlfriend cassidy yates aboard the
defiant bothers him so much
when the defiant finally reaches its
destination the crew is shocked to
discover captain cusack has been dead
for three years
an energy barrier surrounding the planet
somehow allowed for the defiance
transmissions to reach her in the past
and hers to connect with them
in the future they bring cusack back to
ds9 for an irish wake where the crew
gathers to honor her and to share the
lessons their friend taught them
at first star trek the next generations
the offspring seems like it might become
another exploration of the rights of
synthetic life
after data surprises his friends with
the reveal that he's created a new
android named lol
captain picard is extremely concerned
about the ramifications
his fears are realized when a starfleet
admiral demands lol be taken off the
enterprise to be placed under the
supervision of starfleet scientists
hallie todd's portrayal as data's
android daughter lol is sweet funny and
ultimately heartbreaking
like her father lal is confused by human
behavior but does her best to learn
doing things like grabbing will riker
without warning for a kiss or telling
data that she believes she has mastered
the art of humor because so many
children laugh at her
lal unexpectedly grows beyond data's
programming and develops the ability to
feel emotions
unfortunately she can't survive them
after being overcome with fear at the
prospect of separation from data her
systems experience a critical failure
in her final moments she thanks data for
her life and tells him she loves him
when he tells her he wishes he could
feel the same for her she says she will
love enough for them both
star trek has a lot of ways of forcing
illusions on its characters
when it comes to these illusions perhaps
no other trek story proves as harmful to
one of its heroes as ds9's hard time
while visiting the agrathy homeworld
chief miles o'brien is wrongly convicted
of espionage
rather than maintaining physical prisons
the agrathy punished criminals by
implanting memories of incarceration
including hunger isolation and torture
when kira arrives to pick up miles he's
only been in their custody for a few
hours
but he has memories of 20 years worth of
prison
the miles o'brien who returns to ds9 is
a changed man
he prefers to be alone he's angry he
refuses to see his therapist and he
threatens his best friend dr bashir
he eventually gets violent assaulting
quark for taking too long to serve him a
drink and even coming close to hitting
his daughter
it's revealed that during most of his
time in the virtual prison miles has a
kind patient cellmate named ichar after
20 years in the cell with him
wrongly believing his friend is hiding
food from him miles murders each other
hallucinations of ichar appear to obrien
on ds9
only disappearing when on the brink of
ending his own life o'brien finally
accepts help from bashir
and it turns out that even in the future
there's no easy cure for ptsd
written by late author harlan ellison
star trek the original series the city
on the edge of forever is a time travel
episode that forces captain kirk
into an impossible decision the trouble
begins when a temporarily insane bones
flees into a sentient time portal
calling itself the guardian of forever
shortly after he enters the timeline is
altered so that starfleet basically
ceases to exist
kirk and spock follow through the portal
ending up in new york city during the
great depression
believing they're homeless the kind and
forward thinking edith keeler helps the
pair
and she and kirk fall in love
unfortunately spock discovers that
keeler is the subject of the timeline
shift
keeler is supposed to be killed in a car
accident if she survives she'll help
spread a message of pacifism that keeps
america out of world war ii
which in turn leads to germany's victory
but she was right
peace was the way she was right but at
the wrong time
when the moment comes for kirk to decide
it's fast and brutal
kirk and spock find bones and edith
crosses the street to join them without
paying attention to traffic
when the car destined to kill edith
approaches kirk not only stops himself
from helping
but holds on to bones and stops him from
interfering as well
when the trio returns to their crew kirk
has no comforting words for his friends
and ignores the guardian of forever's
invitations for other journeys through
time
one of star trek's first attempts to
explore the plight of lgbtq plus people
was in tng's 1992 episode the outcast
we use a pronoun that is neutral i do
not think there is really a translation
the enterprise encounters the
androgynous race the genai who needs
help finding a lost shuttle in its crew
the enterprise crew determines the
shuttle is in a pocket of what they call
null space
riker partners with the jinai named
soren to find a way to get into null
space to rescue the missing crew
the attraction between riker and soren
is noticed by riker's friends and the
other gennady
soaring confides in riker not only that
she's attracted to him but that she
identifies as a female
for a chennai to identify as either male
or female is forbidden and others like
soren are treated as outcasts
if they're discovered they will undergo
a kind of conversion therapy called
psychotactic treatment
riker and soren's relationship is
discovered before it gets very far
sorin makes a passionate speech in front
of the other gennady and riker tries to
intervene
he takes responsibility for everything
and offers to take sorin with him
the gennady refuse ignoring picard's
warnings riker and wharf
attempt to break soren free they easily
overpower the genai guards but once
riker is alone with soren she's a
different person
the psychotectic treatments are complete
and sorin believed she had been ill
and is now well riker desperately
professes his love for her
but soren simply answers i'm sorry and
walks away
in this bittersweet ds9 episode ben
cisco is believed killed when struck by
a bolt of energy during an accident on
the defiant
for years after the accident ben
continues to briefly appear before his
son jake only to eventually fade away
like a ghost into subspace
after returning to earth jake marries
and finally publishes his novel anslem
to wide acclaim
but after he becomes obsessed with
saving his father jake abandons writing
to pursue scientific study
and his marriage falls apart jake
determines his father keeps appearing
when and where he does because the
accident connected him to jake
and that the only way to save him is for
jake to die during his father's next
appearance
as an elderly man jake awakens to his
father smiling at him
and jake reveals his plan ben is crushed
but it's too late jake has already taken
the drugs that will kill him
as he dies jake tells his father he's
doing it not just for ben
but for the boy that i was
he needs you more than you know
as the elderly jake dies ben appears
years earlier during the accident on the
defiant and ducks the bolt of energy
just in time
if you aren't already tearing up then
embracing his young son while crying
grateful tears should push you over the
edge
this truly bleak episode opens with the
marriage of tom paris and balana torres
but they don't get to enjoy their
honeymoon
the molecular cohesion of voyager is
deteriorating affecting both the ship
itself and the crew inside ballana is
the first to die
the crew discovers something shocking in
the previous season episode demon
voyager had landed on a planet that
created a complete duplicate of the ship
and all her crew
out of biomimetic fluid tuvak and
chakote determine their ship as the
duplicate
and they're now all dying because of
exposure to radiation from their
enhanced warp core
everything the duplicate crew tries ends
in failure when they try to find solace
on a planet they're chased off by aliens
the ship and crew deteriorate too fast
for them to make it back to their home
world and
even an attempt to launch a capsule with
all of their logs fails
few of their crew are left by the time
they detect the original voyager on
their sensors
they try hailing the ship and the
original voyager responds but by the
time they get there all that's left of
the duplicate ship and crew is formless
fluid floating in space
sadly the episode in which we learn the
most about the mysterious star trek
discovery character arium
is project daedalus and also the same
episode in which she dies
it had been clear for a number of
episodes that something was taking over
arium and forcing her to act against her
will
and project daedalus opens with aryam
reviewing her memories and deleting many
of them including the tragic loss of her
husband just after they had eloped
the discovery crew finally figures out
arium is being manipulated by control
section 31's threat assessment ai but
only after arium is alone with michael
and neon on the ransacked section 31 hq
arium nearly kills her colleagues but
regains enough control to insist michael
kill her by opening an airlock while
she's in it
michael refuses insisting arium can
fight control but neon takes the choice
out of michael's hands and opens the
airlock
barium is shot into space and dies but
before she succumbs
tilly uploads the memory of her on the
beach with her fiance so she can see it
one more time
the star trek enterprise episode tara
prime mainly deals with the enterprise's
conflict with the group of the same name
led by john frederick paxton tara prime
is a xenophobic extremist group
dedicated to removing all aliens and
alien influence from earth
among his crueler tactics paxton takes
dna from topal and trip and uses it to
create a half-human half-vulcan clone
infant he displays it as a propaganda
tool
calling it an abomination and uses it as
leverage after he takes to paul and trip
hostage
tara prime is defeated but the baby
doesn't survive the episode
phlox initially believes the baby's
illness and resulting death is due to
the inherent incompatibility of human
and vulcan dna
but in the final scene a devastated trip
tells to paul that the doctor discovered
there was a flaw in the technique used
to create the child and that a human
vulcan child might survive
topol reaches out and grabs tripp's hand
in support a powerful gesture
considering her species and its
philosophies towards emotion
shortly after the enterprise encounters
a probe captain sean luke picard
collapses on the bridge and wakes up to
a woman named delene who claims she's
his wife and tells him that his name is
caiman
understandably picard is convinced
something deceptive is going on
initially believing he's on a holodeck
after five years of no rescue from or
contact with the enterprise picard
accepts his new life on the planet katan
including falling in love with aleene
and regularly trying and failing to
master the catanian flute
the scenes occasionally cut back to the
enterprise where only minutes have
passed but on katan years have gone by
for picard and his new family
finally an elderly picard attends a
celebration with his children
and grandchildren which turns out to be
the launching of the same probe that the
enterprise encounters
the truth is finally revealed that the
probe has given picard the vision of a
lifetime so someone will remember katan
and its people
after the probe deactivates and picard
wakes up about 25 minutes after it
begins transmitting
the crew retrieves it and riker brings
the package it contains to his captain
inside the box is cayman's flute which
picard remembers how to play
thanks to decades of a completely
separate life he's lived and instantly
lost
after returning from a mission where he
went over security procedures for
upcoming peace talks on ds9
o'brien notices everyone is acting
strange keiko is doing everything she
can to keep their daughter away from him
cisco is giving his engineers orders
without talking to him first
beshear is hounding him about getting a
physical and all it takes is a 30-second
conversation with jake sisko for kyra to
jump in and tell jake to go see his
father
it gets to the point where o'brien
worries caicos trying to poison him
o'brien uses his engineering know-how to
escape ds9 in a runabout
and rushed to the paratha system to warn
them and see if he can get to the bottom
of things
he reaches the hideout of the parodin
rebels and the truth is revealed
the real o'brien was imprisoned and a
replicant copy was made of him and sent
back to ds9 in his stead
to disrupt the peace talks the paradigm
rebels discovered the plan
rescued the real o'brien and informed
ds9 of the plot which explains why
everyone was acting strange around him
the replicant o'brien having just
arrived on parada knows none of this
critically injured by one of the rebels
the replicant dies calling out keiko's
name and begging the real o'brien to
tell keiko he loves her
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]